you know if I can help Andrew Mazel Tov
if if that program then helps others at
the cost associated with it Mazel Tov
it's all just [ __ ] good on good on
good and yes I think the way we do
business is going to be the way everyone
does business in the future because it's
going to be required to be successful
and if people can move on that version
faster which is more about EQ than IQ
then they'll be more successful and
that's what I want for people not
successful with money [ __ ] [ __ ] money
successful with content and joy and
happiness of course Money Matters I
don't diss money I'm an entrepreneur I
gotta buy the New York Jets so that's
gonna I'm not gonna be able to win that
I'm not gonna buy the Jets with hearts
but like but you can do both you can you
can be kind and it can be
entrepreneurial it doesn't it doesn't
have to be rugged nice guys finish first
the second you figure out that nice guys
finish first not last is the second good
things will happen in your life first
question for you Gary is
um of course we have to throw in our I
asked
Gary you've dealt with failures all your
life publicly as well it seems to be an
inevitable thing in entrepreneurship but
I'm curious how successful entrepreneurs
like you are able to get past so many
failures but somehow keep going
failures are personal they're not public
when I fail
I have the enjoyment of Leaning into my
addiction of humility
and I love that I've learned and I don't
have to make those same pattern mistakes
in the future so I double win I get
another dose of humility which I achieve
for and strive for and I get a learning
that I'm smart enough and capable enough
of not repeating the reason people are
scared of failure is because they worry
about people's opinions on the outside
their parents their siblings and the
general public Anonymous people on
Twitter and Discord and the world which
is silly because the reality is it's
your life and what you really learn is
you've gotta the reason people are
scared of of failure is because they
have egos they actually think that their
life is that important that people's
Judgment of their failures is important
I know even with my significance of
awareness and popularity success
notoriety that at the end of the day I'm
just one little speck of eight billion
people on Earth during a little 100 Year
window on the universe's trajectory of
all time and so I I'm humbled by that
and thus when I fail that's me with
myself and that has nothing to do with
any of you has nothing to do with any of
you let alone the people closest to me
it has nothing to do with them all of a
sudden once failure becomes an insular
game not an external game failure does
not become scary it actually becomes
interesting
I thought you didn't just like try to
diminish failure
and say it's not failure failure you
leaned into it um correct Andrew it's a
really interesting Insight people like I
didn't fail I learned [ __ ] that [ __ ] you
failed I failed like like Vayner I've
tried to do an events company at vaynerx
for 13 years I've had three stop and
starts those were failures Vayner live
failed I tried to do a sampling company
Vader sampling failed like failure is
real
um it's awesome I love that that [ __ ]
didn't work
follow up um when do you know to shut
something down or look for an exit
strategy when things are maybe you know
when on the other side of failure you
know it but in the middle of it you
don't
okay yeah
yeah I'm looking a lot of faces here
Charles Matt Mazzio like a lot of people
I respect like we've all done good and
bad in that right like
um
oh God you don't know right we sold
empathy wines to consolation right
before covid if we waited six months we
would have done better because everybody
was paying more for DTC Brands right
like so we were wrong even though we had
a massive exit like you know like you
don't know you're guessing but I would
tell for a lot of people here if you're
starting to actually burn out meaning
you don't enjoy it anymore one thing I'm
always fearful of is the following
scenario and this one will land Andrew
for you and many others okay should I
sell this because I'm really actually
not liking it anymore I've got this one
million 10 million 13 million dollar
offer on the table but oh [ __ ] I know
that for the next 24 months I can drive
this train I'll eat a little more [ __ ]
but I can sell it for 25 million
um a lot of people do that and sometimes
it works out the problem is other times
the recession comes interest rates go up
VC stop funding and your 10 million
offer goes to zero I have many friends
publicly known people who passed on
massive exits only to then do an Accu
hire and make Pennies on the dollar for
spending another two and a half years
being unhappy so to me the only
practical answer to your question is
selling it when you're not liking it
because you don't know if it's going to
be financially better or financially
worse because it's out of your control
but you do know that you've sustained
for the last year unhappiness driving it
so you should sell it
I'm sitting I'm happy
to pause that that was great uh Gary
another question from David Salin get a
huge stance shout out David
um what advice do you have from Founders
who maybe are burnt out or they're in
between you know in the phases between
two different things looking to meet the
right folks to start the next thing like
how do you how do they go about figuring
out who the right people are for the
next thing
by putting themselves out there by dming
people right now as they're sitting in
this you know you're people it's all
about fear my friend KP like people are
scared to reach out to somebody people
are scared to network with people
because they're worried about they're
worried about being you know declined I
get this like you know in high school I
was scared to like ask the prettiest
girl out because I didn't want them No
No's are scary but in business I've
never had that and so you know it's just
the truth right it's just the truth like
how to ever go away okay like the fear
of ejection yes by practicing
what people don't understand and this is
where Modern parenting lost their way
the last 30 years modern parenting tried
to eliminate the taste of losing and and
a demonized losing and a demonized
people saying no and so now people are
fully scared of it the way to get there
is by getting a ton of no's
no is good so it's kind of like anything
swimming riding a bike hooking up all
the things that we were scared of
through life you got better at it the
more you did it
and so like you need to ask people like
do you want to have a business meeting
and they they don't reply to your DM or
your email that's good the amount of
people that are mad at me in the world
right now for not replying to their
email is probably quite high but the
reality is is I'm just one human being
and I get 10 000 of them a day I can't
get there and comma the weird part is
it's actually probably equally as good
that I'm not replying to them as if they
actually got the 15 minutes because it's
another at-bat of getting a no
unbelievable Andrew you got a question
another David following up and actually
a a question I think
so this is you Gary how do you handle
the stress of being a founder and
entrepreneur
I don't have the stress of being a
founder and entrepreneur because I found
you know this is why I don't like
garyvee I don't want people to map
towards him because he got lucky I have
to remind everybody I'm 46 years old I'm
gonna be 47 in three weeks I was selling
lemonade at six as my hobby I was
selling baseball cards at 10 as my hobby
it snowed in Edison New Jersey and I
grabbed a shovel in my garage not ran
outside with a sled I love
entrepreneurship and work I'm a very
loud Advocate that I was a dnf student
that was unheard of I want everybody to
understand this there's people in their
40s here that was unheard of
in the 80s especially for an immigrant
from Eastern Europe unheard of I am a
I'm no different than an actress an
athlete a musician I've been this guy
from the beginning I'm like I'm like
Beyonce LeBron not that I'm them in
entrepreneurship but like they didn't
know they were going to do anything else
in their whole life neither did I so
when you ask me do I have stress I don't
have stress I have gratitude every time
I'm losing every time I'm publicly
bashed every time I'm I lose money every
like I get 39 Battle Scars a day but I
love it because I don't do this [ __ ] for
the money or for the fame I've been
doing this long before any of you knew
me I wasn't even a public person until I
was 30 years old to remind everybody now
every person's a public person by the
time they're 15 on Tick Tock this was
not my this is not what I thought I was
gonna do I was just gonna be a
businessman and the world turned in a
certain way that worked out for me from
a popular culture standpoint but it is
not my addiction I don't need your
attention I don't need your admiration I
don't I don't live for it I just I I I
I'm public because I think it's business
development strategy but it is not what
I aspire to do I aspire to be an
entrepreneur so
I am doing my life's Mission I'm I I
feel like I'm a teacher or a guidance
counselor or a religious figure I'm
doing my destiny I'm so [ __ ] happy do
you understand
hello
I'll love that I mean uh Gary the
guidance counselor thing I feel like
it's super overlooked by a lot of people
and and it was one of the indirect
reasons why we started this founder
hotline you know to be honest because we
thought a lot of Founders could use
supported guidance from somebody else
and just like the the support system to
say I hear you I see you that's that's
like takes them a long way so you've
been doing this for decades so I
appreciate it I appreciate you doing
that
um Gary one follow up with the you
mentioned the age thing right and I know
a lot of audience here are above 30
above 40 and I I'm in circles I'm 34
Gary or 46 I'm in circles where people
think
22 is too old you haven't made it yet
how did you develop a healthy
relationship with time Gary that's my
question
I hung out with 80 year olds when I was
a kid
I gravitated towards grandparents and
great grandparents
um from a very young age my best friend
when we first came to America because we
were poor and everybody was working was
my great grandfather
he passed unfortunately a year into
being in America but I have always
gravitated towards them and what you
learn when you spend time with 80 year
olds if I could tell anybody anything
here
spend time with an 80 year old that is
not your grandparent just have a combo a
dinner strike up a conversation to this
day the only people I strike up
conversations with at airports are
people that I think look like Yoda like
are they 90 I want to talk to them
because they've lived it they give you
context and I'm practical like you're 36
KP right like think about this think
about
think about uh 15 years ago when you
were 21 you probably remember your 21st
birthday right
it feels like yesterday and it feels
like seven trillion years ago right
right so if you think about those 15
years you can think about how much
you've accomplished how much opportunity
you had whether you accomplished it or
not how many reps how many at bats how
much time that actually is now what I do
is when I'm 36 and I do that 15 thing
then I go in 15 years I'll be 51. when
you hang out with older people you
realize 51's a child
I have unlimited 50 60 and 70 year old
friends who act no different than my 30
year old friends and so a lot of you see
me publicly going deep into youth
culture I love the kids I love the Gen
zers the young Millennials but I spend a
lot of my not public time with 60 70 80
year olds and it's context and that
context allows me to understand
brilliant Andrew yeah so all up around
time so this is from Nina
um how do you prioritize your time how
do you make decisions on within you just
gave us a little bit of a sense of older
versus younger uh but how do you just
with a thousand priorities in a day say
this is what I'm going to focus on now
today next I have three full-time admins
and Two Chiefs of Staff
we have a one-hour meeting every
Thursday to look at the week ahead we
analyze every minute on the minute the
meeting I had right before here was a
15-minute meeting the meeting before
that was a 15-minute meeting
um I get a lot done because I believe in
15s I think everybody in here has one
hour meetings that are actually seven
minute meetings you multiply that times
183 meetings a year you can imagine what
ends up happening with efficiency
I go with my intuition in my gut I've
got a ton of things going on I have
eight different companies inside of
vaynerx the holding company and I'm the
active CEO of vaynermedia so I'm a
chairman of seven other companies within
that holding Co I have V friends which
is taking up an enormous amount of time
I have my family my personal life I have
my non-profits I have garyvee the brand
I have tons of Investments I have a fund
I have a lot going on but the real
answer and this is gonna be a bomb the
real answer is I don't judge myself when
the last week wasn't as efficient as it
could have been
the number one reason that people
struggle with time management is because
they beat themselves up for not having a
productive week day or year
and they don't realize that it's just
subjective and they're grading their own
homework and they're [ __ ] themselves
up
anymore I think the productivity
cultures sometimes taking us to the
extreme yeah because productivity is
subjective when people like Gary you're
saying yes to too many things I'm like
let me tell you something I said yes to
that you would have said no to that led
to X and I achieved more financial
success with that Serendipity than you
did with your entire [ __ ] strategy of
douchiness
there's a threat here of compounding you
you pick an attitude you pick a mindset
and then you let it ride and you can't
get in your own way
um but keep it wrong yeah next question
so Sean Huntington asks what are the
soft skills that make for a great
founder what role has kindness played in
building your success Gary
Foundation to retention retention is how
you build a real company number one
uh I think accountability is number one
I am baffled by leaders ability to blame
everybody but themselves if you're a
leader by Nature everything is your
fault and so I took accountability and
everything that's happened in my
personal life and my professional life
and everything in between and so it
doesn't mean I mean I have plenty of
feelings in my personal and professional
life of like what the other parties had
to do uh and and but I don't spend time
on blame or dwelling the number one
characteristic of a a winner leader is
uh is accountability I think compassion
and empathy is the next the reason I
hold no grudges is I understand why
and so I think compassion
and empathy mixed in with accountability
I think competitiveness is a major
factor I think the world has demonized
competition in the last 30 years in a
very unfortunate way I think eighth
place trophies actually lead to a lot of
anxiety and depression with children now
20 and 30 year olds not the reverse
Merit matters and so I think
competitiveness matters tenacity
ambition uh these are kind of the hard
soft skills and then on the soft soft
skills it's definitely kindness empathy
caring being sweet approachable like I
just don't understand how people don't
know that likability is a direct
correlation to something that's healthy
what does that how does that show up for
a Founder I'm going to turn it back
towards the day one yeah very focused
topic right someone who's a solopreneur
they're in their own head they don't
have a team they obviously have people
how does that come home for somebody
who's starting a business
when you're kind to your vendors to your
potential customers to the customers
that fired you
you win
see it's it the big problem is that
people say like I'm kind and then I
double click into it with a Founder that
I'm an investor in or a leader in my
company as I go you're kind when it's
easy
right next year it's going to be hard
the economy is getting softer there's a
lot going on
like are you kind when it's rough
right how does it show up for a
solopreneur solopreneur is scared she
didn't hear scrapping they're trying to
get by they don't want to go back to
their job so when you're scared and
scrapping the ability to be I'll give
you an example you're a solopreneur you
got a customer
they're paying you a thousand bucks a
month you're pumped they fire you a
month in because they have a problem are
you going to be kind and gracious to
them or are you gonna be like [ __ ] you
most people go to [ __ ] you
I think if you go to kind and gracious
and understanding even though it's a gut
punch to you that that comes around long
term and it matters
man I just want to ask everybody because
I'm like looking in the mirror that's so
real and life is getting harder right
the economy is getting harder we're all
going to face that let me get let me
give let me give you a super macro one
you being kind in every scenario on the
way to your ship sinking is exactly how
you're going to get a meaningful job
on the other side of your failed startup
and people just don't look at the bigger
picture
[Music]
I I love that long game I love that long
game I think that's
the KP yeah uh well I mean I'm just kind
of reflecting on it um so I have another
question that's a little bit more
tactical
um so again this is by John Wayman and
John Wayne's a therapist and marriage
counselor and is it very successful I
want to read so here's the question I
want to grow my practice by pursuing
therapists and coaches to follow more
customer friendly model which I think
assessment model over charging and
billing for hours I can't find people to
do this how do I go about doing that by
pounding the narrative into the universe
at scale I couldn't find entrepreneurs
that wanted to be empathetic and kind to
their their VCS their employees their
vendors and then I just made Seven
trillion pieces of creative over a
10-year period and I'll miraculously you
find more and at first it was dozens and
then it was hundreds and then it was
thousands every single person here that
wants something accomplished has to
realize that
scaled creative in Social channels
and then doing unscalable work I see
Greg s in here right who's behind hi-ho
that q a platform leads to depth like
I've never seen which is why I decided
to get behind it
um and so you know there's depth there's
width but it's all about creative like
you know the world was changed by
writers by Poets by musicians by public
speakers everyone here can have the
world they want the problem is most
people that are trying to do good or
optimism are quieter than people that
are trying to do negativity and bad
negativity and darkness and bad is loud
they're on the offense
positivity and happiness is content
thus not pushing themselves to be loud
one of the biggest things that I'm
trying to do is be loud in the face of
negativity right I see Vicki one of my
favorites Vicki J just like that like
like in the face of anything and
everything I always want to go positive
and do good and I'm empathetic to
people's feelings but I'm always going
to push positive things because it is
positive life is complicated there's a
lot of variables there's a lot of
nuances but positivity in this room
needs to be louder and so if he wants
that the reason he's not finding it is
he's not putting it into the universe
enough more creative more written word
more audio more video more jumping into
me saying yes to this I had these 30
minutes
as if like I would have rather have
somebody take a razor and slash my face
than allocate the 30 minutes to this
given how much work I have to do before
January 1st and yet I said yes to this
because intuitively I felt that I could
leave a positive impact in these 30
minutes to somebody within the 2 000
people that are sitting here right now
and I was like [ __ ] it and so it's
painful and like after I hang up I'm
like [ __ ] I really probably needed that
30 minutes but then in nine months 16
months four years somebody here is going
to email me and say I was listening to
Twitter spaces you said something about
accountability or kindness and it
changed my life and then all of a sudden
it's all [ __ ] Pro
couldn't cosign that more I mean the
very fact that I'm here with you carry
was because 10 years ago I was listening
to one of these things that you did and
I decided I'm going to be an
entrepreneur I'm gonna I'm gonna show up
for myself and after 10 years here I am
with you so it's crazy how different
facts work but two last bits Andrew I
know we have the big announcement I
can't wait for Gary to talk about that I
know we've been arrested in love I can't
wait to you know get Gary's perspective
on it I want you to announce it
for a little bit Andrew Dopey Andrew
don't be mad at me I'm so pumped I
didn't realize you were announcing what
we've been working on in this in this
format so
[Music]
but the biggest the biggest question
everybody the elephant in the room
everyone's wondering pondering thinking
about but not mentioning Gary recession
yes macro wise everyone's freaking out
the banks are freaking out every every
news channel is like freaking out I feel
like there's a lot of Theater economy
going on but what is your take on it
from your Vantage Point number two how
should entrepreneurs Founders business
people think about this turn fear into
common sense and practicality and
humility and everything will be Beyond
okay
let me say that nice and slow so
everyone understands you should be
fearful things are happening
Apple doesn't shut down production of
iPhones for its Health Banks don't do
what they are doing right now which is
clamping the [ __ ] down right VCS don't
even know they got tons of dollars to
deploy they're smart what are they going
to just write a check at a higher
valuation when they know the Market's
going to be different in six months this
is real this is the time to not waste
money as a company or as a human being
maybe you don't need Starbucks every day
maybe you shouldn't order from Postmates
every day maybe you should cook in your
little apartment maybe you don't need to
take an Uber maybe you don't need to do
these things like me you definitely
don't need to be buying [ __ ] that you
don't need you don't need to upgrade
your car you may not need a bigger
television you may not need 17 employees
maybe it's 11. it's devastating because
you don't want bad for those six people
but like you if you go out of business
then all 17 people are out of business
right so
don't take it as fear it's just real
life
actually realize the last 10 years you
should have been grateful for and you
should add gratitude for how easy it was
covet wasn't hard covet was easy the
government printed an unlimited amount
of money why do you think we're here I
love how people like it's their fault
it's not their fault who printed all the
[ __ ] money we printed all the money
like I don't understand like how people
understand like there's nothing common
sense or natural about I'm gonna sit at
home and the government's going to pay
me more to sit at home than have an
actual [ __ ] job it sounded all fun
but the problem was people bought
[ __ ] Dom p and [ __ ] PlayStation
fives with that money like don't you
understand people are confused out here
they're living insecure and they need
stuff to patch up their insecurity or to
flex in front of others life is about
self-esteem period end of story and so
what do I think I think everyone should
be very thoughtful about every dollar
they have now look I I have lots of
savings so I don't have to change
anything I can not do anything for seven
years different so I'm less worried but
if I could if I had to change my
lifestyle I would immediately and I'm
Gonna Change My Lifestyle because
there's going to be opportunities and
I'd rather buy a business during this
time than have another extra fancy
dinner like people need to get the
[ __ ] smart be practical like I don't
know what you think is going to happen
don't [ __ ] hope
and don't ask the government to do
something for you like [ __ ] do it for
yourself
there's the wake up this is awesome I
only wish one thing that this was
somehow like somebody should leaked Mr
Bloomberg CNBC
whatever they're playing on on TV Karen
thank you so much all right the last
segment angel I want you to reflect on
I'm gonna reflect basically like
announce to the world the big the big
news about the partnership yeah and Gary
I want you to react to it give your two
cents on it go on here we go 30 seconds
on this I mentioned before we ran a
vaynerx incubator over the summer it was
an awesome first take at our
collaboration between day one vaynerx
we're running it back we have a new
program launching it's going live in q1
it's live now it's a track within the
day one Fellowship that is uh where
you'll get to connect with and learn
from the leaders The Operators from
within vaynerx it's called the
leadership and operations track it's a
new program
where you know Gary's and the vaynerx uh
approach to leadership in business are
going to get uh up front and center so
you get the killer combination of a day
one program with the community and the
collaboration with your peers with
everything the learning entrepreneurship
from some of the best and so that's live
right now Gary before I'm turning the
mic because I'm going to let you have
the last word for everyone on this call
we're giving a special announcement
launch discount for the first 50 people
who sign up there's a code for 50 off
it's hotline 50. like the founder
hotline hotline 50. part of the site
first 50 people but no that was it
that's the infomercial
is referring to is joinday1.com
j-o-i-n-d-a-y-o-n-d.com okay so Andrew I
heard you pitch everyone's pumped Gary
can you mix the same thing in your words
look I I love the day I love Andrew and
his co-founder like you know I invested
I want them to win the biggest thing I
can bring them value is the Vayner
operational way the Vayner x-way I have
30 40 50 100 Executives now that have
been with me for almost a decade uh they
love giving back this is just a good you
know it's a it's a honestly what is this
this is karma on top of karma on top of
karma you know if I can help Andrew
Mazel Tov if if that program then helps
others uh at the cost associated with it
Mazel Tov it's all just [ __ ] good on
good on good and yes I think the way we
do business is going to be the way
everyone does business in the future
because it's going to be required to be
successful and if people can move on
that version faster which is more about
EQ than IQ then they'll be more
successful and that's what I want for
people not successful with money [ __ ]
[ __ ] money successful with content and
joy and happiness of course Money
Matters I don't diss money I'm an
entrepreneur I gotta buy the New York
Jets so that's gonna I'm not gonna be
able to win that I'm not gonna buy the
Jets with Parts but like but you can do
both you can you can be kind and it can
be entrepreneurial it doesn't it doesn't
have to be rugged nice guys finish first
the second you figure out the nice guys
finish first not last is the second good
things will happen in your life I have
to run I'm two minutes late for
something else love you hit me up on
Twitter right now I'm gonna be reading
it because the meeting I'm in to see
what you most took away from this
meeting love you see you love you see
you bye
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]